Yeah.
To me at the time I thought this is it.
Like we are not compatible.
Like we actually may break up after this trip when we get home.
Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
Happy to do this.
I know
I'm Wally and I'm walking on her channel.
We blog about food or pets just everyday,
daily life.
Our life is kind of interesting.
I don't know.
I guess it must be right.
Our relationship with your best friends.
It doesn't really feel like a relationship.
Yeah.
We're each other's best friend.
Yeah,
so I met him when we were in middle school and I thought he was real queue.
He was,
I'm really tall,
but when I heard his voice I was like,
Ooh,
it sounds like a girl.
It's handed over
my first impression of her.
Um,
hey,
look,
another Chinese person in the town.
There wasn't much of an impression.
It was just like,
oh,
and I'm the Chinese girl.
How romantic.
He's looking at me in the eyes just saying.
Not at all.
No.
Colandra all right.
See how it is.
Ooh.
Our first date was at a Sushi restaurant in our hometown.
I think Ellen,
then we had frozen yogurt after that.
I don't think you're going to get this one.
I don't think he's going to remember
my first day.
Um,
oh,
it's not a bait that was in the bay.
Oh Man.
I messed up.
We went to San Francisco.
It's so hard cause it wasn't even like a date date like that.
It was just like me and her and her sister went out to San Francisco,
San Francisco.
That was the best Sushi at that really quiet restaurant.
That was our day to day.
Oh,
he's made me become a better person.
He's always very,
very considerate.
I've learned a lot from him.
Very,
very generous.
Always willing to like help friends,
help family.
My family.
He's really funny.
I think my sense of humor now comes from him.
He's a great person and I love everything.
Patience.
She's got so much patience.
She puts up with so much,
um,
me and everyone around her.
Um,
I said everything pretty much everything.
Yeah.
Nicolock.
Why are you lying
for me?
I said I love your patients the most.
Hmm.
You have some which patients for me and for everyone else around you.
I should've said that one to learn some of that from you.
I don't think it's changed our relationship much.
I think it's taught both of us as individuals that we could be more mindful of
things that we would say because we used to just have no filter at all.
Uh,
I guess it would just be when we go out and if we go somewhere where we're
getting noticed too much,
but it has made us more comfortable with each other being on camera together.
It's different from being together.
Being on camera together has made us realize things that we wouldn't if there
was no camera around.
Okay.
We always know when to take the break.
Like if ever we feel,
oh,
this is consuming too much of our lives,
then we'll take a break.
I think it's most important to be yourself on camera because when you are not
being yourself,
that's when you start changing.
I guess that's what I think people started doing it for the right.
Right.
Do you want to portray a perfect relationship?
Exactly.
Biggest fight together.
I think the fight,
two months ago
we had a fight on vacation,
so we were in Hawaii and this bus driver was really mean to me and our friends.
So he kind of like raised his voice at the bus driver.
It's like I can't even get mad at him for this because he gets mad when he sees
someone disrespecting me.
So it comes from a place where he's being very protective of me at the moment I,
I was mad at him.
I was like,
wow,
really?
We're on vacation and you want to get in a fight with this bus driver.
And then I told him why I was upset.
He told me why he was upset.
We just didn't agree at the time.
So throughout the entire vacation we were just ignoring each other.
My thought,
this is it,
like we are not compatible and we haven't talked for three days and I fault just
even he doesn't want to work on it.
And that's like the first time I've ever felt that from him.
And I thought that would be the meaning of love.
You know
that you will
always work that your problems together.
We were in Hawaii,
we were in a trip.
Yeah.
I wish this I'm a really hard time for,
for the both of us for her is because I made it a hard time for,
um,
I wish this,
it was just a bad,
that's all I can say.
It was just bad man.
But I feel like through that argument we really have learned so much about each
other.
Um,
and it's crazy to think that light at almost seven years you,
there's some more to learn about this person.
I think that made me realize how much I need her and
how much I can do without her.
I think when I talked to my girlfriends or just people in general,
I was,
I would always say,
Oh,
if you did that to me,
we're done.
And I think a lot of people can easily say that because that's their pride
speaking the one I realized how serious it was and that we were reaching a
point.
Oh Wow.
Like we actually may break up after this trip when we get home.
That's when I reevaluated everything.
Why were even fighting?
What does this mean to me and do I want to fix it?
[inaudible] did.
Yup.
Thank you.
Everything.
Um,
uh,
I mean my life would be shattered.
Well,
I'm crying because that's like my worst nightmare.
I feel like it's because I truly cannot live without him.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're just my everything.
Hmm.
What do you too,
I wouldn't miss everything.
Literally everything.
Take one,
take one.
We spend so much time with each other and we love it.
Um,
that it really feels like she's like literally a part of me.
Like we share a bond in between that if broken and actually hurts.
Um,
I said,
I'll miss everything.
I'll probably die.
Yeah.
Because I used to clean them,
know how to live.
I said that we share a bond together.
That it feels like we're in the same body.
That if any of that wasn't broken,
it would actually physically hurt.
[inaudible] you make it really easy to love you.
You make me happy,
make me feel safe,
make me feel beautiful.
I think our relationship like that,
that we are really just best friends and not just seeing that we are best
friends.
Like we really are just best friends and lovers.
And I think that there's something in that that it's hard to explain to put it
into words.
Yeah.
Whoa.
I know love is a weird thing.
It is.
Cause it's,
it's more of a feeling you,
you know,
why you like someone like a friend because certain things they do for you,
but when you love someone,
it's,
it's just that feeling.
I love you very much.
I said I could definitely see us lasting forever.
That it won't last forever.
Okay.